and here's a guy right here he's in the
program what step do you think he's on
I bet he's been in probably about seven
or eight years this guy looks like my
brother a little bit actually no it
doesn't look like hey what's up guys
okay crystally and bryan callen if you
kind of mix them together maybe it looks
like Lovato junior a little bit yeah
that's what I was thinking too
Demi Lovato junior no ruled up guys is
Casey from Los Angeles had a little King
and her sting it for you I know Eddie on
the last flight companion went a little
deaf Jack Russell and she so I just
wanted to throw it out there Rat King on
the next fight companion King under
staying it Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
young man I would love it I'd love free
to be on this doesn't he look like
Lovato jr. right there oh yes there you
go another one I love it field came on
the fight campaign Rogan likes the
original crew though I tried getting
Joey Diaz on too you know he just likes
the original four yeah I think if you
have something good that were I mean I
would love to go on you know I don't
know enough about fighting I don't think
I don't know I mean like we talked three
minutes about fighting the rest about
random [ __ ] that you and I talked about
so I think you'd be just fine
yeah I mean I think you know doesn't
pour a something might get your foot in
the door yeah it'd be fun but yeah I
don't know I watch the fights use your
text Nick and ask her to bet on and then
I'll lose some money and then I go did
you give him Walt Harris over over II
know I stated that away from that one
because I was like I thought over an
easy pig
I thought Overeem would win but I didn't
want to bet against the guy whose
daughter got murdered I felt I felt
conflicted I went to I went three and
one I thought I got lucky on cheedo Vera
I thought or unlucky I thought he won
but then but then I went on a gay and I
thought he lost so I went three and one
that's fun that's really good there's
some fun Pike MMA stuff to bet on dude
the tough sport Jeff's s 5 & 7 says I'll
return from pandemic 5 & 7 yeah not
great it was a bloodbath last week I
like da damage right
I like you boy damage lol come yeah head
took some damage he reminds me of every
every do to my neighborhood but now with
an adult
wonderful fire yes 85 like this people
who got that kind of tattoos like
somebody would come and be like hey man
look I got the guy from monopoly in my
back and it took literally seven weeks
to do it in somebody's end of the needle
and like a blogger
yeah and barely got it done and then the
guy would be sick for like four years
like a you know a blood thing
[Music]